HERE IS PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN.
>> BEFORE I UPDATE YOU ON THE
MEETING THAT I HAD WITH LEADERS
OF THE G7 EARLIER TODAY, I WANT
TO SAY A WORD ABOUT THE PROGRESS
WE'RE MAKING ON THE BUILD BACK
BETTER AGENDA HERE AT HOME.
I JUST GOT OFF THE TELEPHONE
WITH THE LEADERS OF THE HOUSE.
TODAY THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES ARE TAKING
SIGNIFICANT STEPS TOWARD MAKING
HISTORIC INVESTMENT THAT'S GOING
TO TRANSFORM AMERICA, CUT TAXES
FOR WORKING FAMILIES AND
POSITION THE AMERICAN ECONOMY
FOR LONG-TERM GROWTH.
WHEN I BECAME PRESIDENT, IT WAS
CLEAR THAT WE HAD COULD CONFRONT
AN IMMEDIATE ECONOMIC CRISIS,
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT RECESSION
WE'VE HAD SINCE THE DEPRESSION,
OR AT LEAST SINCE JOHNSON.
BUT WE WEREN'T GOING TO -- BUT
THAT WASN'T GOING TO BE ENOUGH.
WE ALSO HAD TO MAKE SOME
LONG-TERM INVESTMENTS IN
AMERICANS AND AMERICA ITSELF.
THE FIRST THING WE DID WAS TO
WRITE AND PASS THE AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN.
AND IT'S WORKING.
OUR ECONOMY HAS ADDED 4 MILLION
JOBS IN MY FIRST SIX MONTHS IN
OFFICE.
ECONOMIC GROWTH IS UP TO THE
FASTEST IT'S BEEN, FASTEST RATE
IN 40 YEARS.
AND UNEMPLOYMENT IS COMING DOWN.
RIGHT NOW OUR ECONOMIC GROWTH IS
LEADING THE WORLD'S ADVANCED
ECONOMIES.
BUT TO WIN THE FUTURE WE NEED TO
TAKE THE NEXT STEP.
TODAY THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES DID JUST THAT.
TODAY'S VOTE IN THE HOUSE
ALLOWED THEM TO CONSIDER MY
BUILD BACK BETTER AGENDA, A
BROAD FRAMEWORK TO MAKE HOUSING
MORE AFFORDABLE, BRING DOWN THE
COST OF PRESCRIPTION DRUGS BY
GIVE THE MEDICARE THE POWER TO
NEGOTIATE LOWER DRUGS FOR PRICES
OF DRUGS, MAKE ELDER CARE MOST
ARE AFFORDABLE, PROVIDING TWO
FREE YEARS OF COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
CONTINUE TO GIVE THE MIDDLE
CLASS FAMILIES THE WELL-DESERVED
TAX CUT FOR DAYCARE AND
HEALTHCARE THAT THEY DESERVE,
ALLOWING A LOT OF WOMEN TO GET
BACK TO WORK PRIMARILY.
AND PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT MONTHLY
TAX CUTS FOR WORKING FAMILIES
WITH CHILDREN THROUGH THE
CHILDCARE TAX CREDIT.
THESE INVESTMENTS ARE GOING TO
LOWER OUT-OF-POCKET EXPENSES FOR
FAMILIES AND NOT JUST GIVE THEM
A LITTLE MORE BREATHING ROOM.
IN ADDITION, WE'RE GOING TO MAKE
LONG, OVERDUE MUCH NEEDED
INVESTMENTS IN BASIC, HARD
INFRASTRUCTURE OF THIS NATION.
THIS SCENARIO WHERE WE HAVE
BROAD BIPARTISAN AGREEMENT TO
INVEST IN OUR ANTIQUATED ROADS,
HIGHWAYS, BRIDGES, TRANSIT,
DRINKING WATER SYSTEMS,
BROADBAND, CLEAN ENERGY,
ENVIRONMENTAL CLEANUP, AND MAKE
OUR INFRASTRUCTURE MORE
RESILIENT TO THE CLIMATE CRISIS
AND SO MUCH MORE.
THIS IS ALL PAID FOR.
INSTEAD OF GIVING EVERY BREAK IN
THE WORLD TO CORPORATIONS AND
CEOs, BY THE WAY, 55 OF OUR
LARGEST COMPANIES IN AMERICA
PAID $0 IN FEDERAL TAXES ON MORE
THAN $40 BILLION IN PROFIT LAST
YEAR.
WE CAN ASK CORPORATIONS AND THE
VERY WEALTHY JUST TO PAY THEIR
FAIR SHARE.
THEY CAN STILL MAKE A LOT OF
MONEY, BUT JUST BEGIN TO PAY
THEIR FAIR SURE.
SO WE CAN INVEST IN MAKING OUR
COUNTRY STRONGER AND MORE
COMPETITIVE.
CREATE JOBS AND RAISE WAGES AND
LIFT UP THE STANDARD OF LIVING
FOR EVERYONE.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS WE'RE A STEP
CLOSER TO TRULY INVESTING IN THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, POSITIONING OUR
ECONOMY FOR LONG-TERM GROWTH,
AND BUILDING AN AMERICA THAT
OUTCOMPETES THE REST OF THE
WORLD.
MY GOAL IS TO BUILD AN ECONOMY
FROM THE BOTTOM UP AND THE
MIDDLE OUT, NOT JUST THE TOP
DOWN.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE ON OUR WAY
OF DOING.
LOOK, I WANT TO THANK SPEAKER
PELOSI WHO WAS MASTERFUL IN HER
LEADERSHIP ON THIS.
AND THE ENTIRE HOUSE LEADERSHIP
TEAM FOR THE HARD WORK,
DEDICATION, AND DETERMINATION TO
BRING PEOPLE TOGETHER SO WE CAN
MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN PEOPLE'S
LIVES.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK EVERY
DEMOCRAT IN THE HOUSE WHO WORKED
SO HARD OVER THE PAST FEW WEEKS
TO REACH AN AGREEMENT AND WHO
SUPPORTED THE PROCESS FOR HOUSE
CONSIDERATION OF THE JOBS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN, THE BUILD
BACK BETTER EFFORT.
THERE WERE DIFFERENCES, STRONG
POINTS OF VIEW.
THEY'RE ALWAYS WELCOME.
WHAT IS IMPORTANT IS THAT WE
CAME TOGETHER TO ADVANCE OUR
AGENDA.
I THINK EVERYONE WHO DID THAT, I
THINK EVERYONE WHO DID IT WAS
THERE.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK EVERYONE
WHO VOTED TO SUPPORT THE JOHN
LEWIS VOTING RIGHTS ACT.
IT'S AN ACT TO RESTORE AND
EXPAND VOTING PROTECTIONS, TO
PREVENT VOTER SUPPRESSION, AND
TO SECURE THE MOST SACRED OF
AMERICAN RIGHTS, THE RIGHT TO
VOTE FREELY, THE RIGHT TO VOTE
FAIRLY, AND THE RIGHT TO HAVE
YOUR VOTE COUNTED.
THE SENATE ALSO HAS TO JOIN THEM
TO SEND THIS IMPORTANT BILL TO
MY DESK.
AND THE SENATE HAS TO MOVE
FORWARD ON THE PEOPLES ACT.
CRITICAL LEGISLATION TO PROTECT
OUR DEMOCRACY AND THE RIGHT TO
VOTE.
WE NEED BOTH OF THOSE ELECTION
BILLS.
BUT LET ME NOW TURN TO
AFGHANISTAN.
I MET THIS MORNING WITH MY
COUNTERPARTS IN THE G7, AS WELL
AS HEADS OF THE UNITED NATIONS,
NATO, AND THE EUROPEAN UNION.
I EXPRESSED MY THANKS FOR THE
SOLIDARITY WE HAVE SEEN AS WE'VE
STOOD UP AN UNPRECEDENTED GLOBAL
EFFORT.
I UPDATED OUR PARTNERS ON A
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS WE MADE IN
THE PAST TEN DAYS.
AS OF THIS AFTERNOON, WE'VE
HELPED EVACUATE 70,700 PEOPLE
JUST SINCE AUGUST THE 14th.
75,900 PEOPLE SINCE THE END OF
JULY.
JUST IN THE PAST 12 HOURS,
ANOTHER 19 U.S. MILITARY
FLIGHTS, 18 C-17s, CARRYING
APPROXIMATELY 6,400 EVACUEES,
AND 31 COALITION FLIGHTS
CARRYING 5,600 PEOPLE HAVE LEFT
KABUL JUST IN THE LAST 12 HOURS.
THE TOTAL OF 50 MORE FLIGHTS,
12,000 MORE PEOPLE SINCE I'VE
UPDATED YOU THIS MORNING.
THESE NUMBERS ARE A TESTAMENT TO
THE EFFORTS OF OUR BRAVE SERVICE
WOMEN AND MEN, TO OUR DIPLOMATS
ON THE GROUND IN KABUL, AND TO
OUR ALLIES STILL STANDING WITH
US.
AND WE HAD A PRODUCTIVE
DISCUSSION.
THERE IS STRONG AGREEMENT AMONG
THE LEADERS BOTH ABOUT THE
EVACUATION MICTION UNDERWAY AS
WELL AS THE NEED TO COORDINATE
OUR APPROACH TO THE AFGHAN -- TO
AFGHANISTAN AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
FIRST ON EVACUATION.
WE AGREE THAT WE WILL CONTINUE
OUR CLOSE COOPERATION TO GET
PEOPLE OUT AS EFFICIENTLY AND
SAFELY AS POSSIBLE.
WE ARE CURRENTLY ON THE PACE TO
FINISH BY AUGUST THE 31st.
THE SOONER WE CAN FINISH, THE
BETTER.
EACH DAY OF OPERATIONS BRINGS
ADDED RISK TO OUR TROOPS.
BUT THE COMPLETION BY AUGUST
31st DEPENDS UPON THE TALIBAN
CONTINUING TO COOPERATE AND
ALLOW ACCESS TO THE AIRPORT FOR
THOSE WHO WE'RE TRANSPORTING OUT
AND NO DISRUPTIONS TO OUR
OPERATIONS.
IN ADDITION, I'VE ASKED THE
PENTAGON AND THE STATE
DEPARTMENT FOR CONTINGENCY PLANS
TO ADJUST THE TIMETABLE SHOULD
THAT BECOME NECESSARY.
I'M DETERMINED TO ENSURE THAT WE
COMPLETE OUR MISSION, THIS
MISSION.
I'M ALSO MINDFUL OF THE
INCREASING RISKS THAT I'VE BEEN
BRIEFED ON AND THE NEED TO
FACTOR THOSE RISKS IN.
THEY'RE REAL AND SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES THAT WE ALSO HAVE TO
TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION.
THE LONGER WE STAY STARTING WITH
THE ACUTE AND GROWING RISK OF AN
ATTACK BY A TERRORIST GROUP
KNOWN AS ISIS-K, AN ISIS
AFFILIATE IN AFGHANISTAN, WHICH
IS A SWORN ENEMY OF THE TALIBAN
AS WELL.
EVERY DAY WE'RE ON THE GROUND IS
ANOTHER DAY WE KNOW THAT ISIS-K
IS SEEKING TO TARGET THE AIRPORT
AND ATTACK BOTH U.S. AND ALLIED
FORCES AND INNOCENT CIVILIANS.
ADDITIONALLY, THUS FAR, THE
TALIBAN HAVE BEEN TAKING STEPS
TO WORK WITH US SO WE CAN GET
OUR PEOPLE OUT.
BUT IT'S A TENUOUS SITUATION.
WE ALREADY HAD SOME GUNFIGHTING
BREAK OUT.
WE RUN A SERIOUS RISK OF IT
BREAKING DOWN AS TIME GOES ON.
SECOND, THE G7 LEADERS AND THE
LEADERS OF THE E.U., NATO, AND
THE U.N. ALL AGREED THAT WE WILL
STAND UNITED IN OUR APPROACH TO
THE TALIBAN.
WE AGREED THE LEGITIMACY OF ANY
FUTURE GOVERNMENT DEPENDS ON THE
APPROACH IT NOW TAKES TO UPHOLD
INTERNATIONAL OBLIGATIONS
INCLUDING TO PREVENT AFGHANISTAN
FROM BEING USED AS A BASE FOR
TERRORISM.
AND WE AGREE THAT NONE OF US ARE
GOING TO TAKE THE TALIBAN'S WORD
FOR IT.
WE'LL JUDGE THEM BY THEIR
ACTIONS AND WE'LL STAY IN CLOSE
COORDINATION ON ANY STEPS THAT
WE TAKE MOVING FORWARD IN
RESPONSE TO THE TALIBAN'S
BEHAVIOR.
AT THE SAME TIME, WE RENEWED OUR
HUMANITARIAN COMMITMENT TO THE
AFGHAN PEOPLE AND SUPPORTED A
PROPOSAL BY THE SECRETARY
GENERAL WITH UNFETTERED
HUMANITARIAN ACCESS IN
AFGHANISTAN.
THIRD, WE TALKED ABOUT OUR
MUTUAL OBLIGATION TO SUPPORT
REFUGEES AND EVACUEES CURRENTLY
FLEEING AFGHANISTAN.
THE UNITED STATES WILL BE A
LEADER IN THESE EFFORTS, AND
WE'LL LOOK TO THE INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNITY AND TO OUR PARTNERS TO
DO THE SAME.
WE'RE ALREADY SEEING OUR ALLIES'
COMMITMENT.
THEY'RE BRINGING TO THEIR
COUNTRIES THE AFGHANS WHO SERVED
ALONGSIDE THEIR FORCES AS
TRANSLATORS OR IN THEIR
EMBASSIES JUST AS WE'RE BRINGING
TO THE UNITED STATES THOSE
AFGHANS WHO WORKED ALONGSIDE OUR
FORCES AND DIPLOMATS.
WE'RE CONDUCTING THOROUGH
SECURITY SCREENING AND THE
INTERMEDIATE STOPS THEY ARE
MAKING FOR ANYONE WHO IS NOT A
U.S. CITIZEN OR A LAWFUL
PERMANENT RESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
ANYONE ARRIVING IN THE UNITED
STATES WILL HAVE UNDERGONE A
BACKGROUND CHECK.
AND WE MUST ALL WORK TOGETHER TO
RESETTLE THOUSANDS OF AFGHANS
WHO ULTIMATELY QUALIFY FOR
REFUGEE STATUS.
THE UNITED STATES WILL DO OUR
PART, AND WE ARE ALREADY WORKING
CLOSELY WITH REFUGEE
ORGANIZATIONS TO REBUILD THE
SYSTEM THAT WAS PURPOSEFULLY
DESTROYED BY MY PREDECESSOR.
FINALLY, WE AGREED TO STAY
VIGILANT AGAINST TERRORIST
THREATS THAT HAVE METASTASIZED
AROUND THE WORLD.
WE WENT TO AFGHANISTAN IN 2001
FOR CLEAR REASONS.
ONE, TO GET THE PEOPLE WHO
ATTACKED US ON 9/11 AND TO GET
OSAMA BIN LADEN AND TO MAKE SURE
THAT AFGHANISTAN WAS NOT USED
AGAIN AS A BASE FROM WHICH TO
ATTACK THE UNITED STATES OR OUR
ALLIES.
WE ACHIEVED THAT OBJECTIVE.
WE DELIVERED JUSTICE TO BIN
LADEN MORE THAN A DECADE AGO.
BUT THE CURRENT ENVIRONMENT
LOOKS VERY DIFFERENT THAN IT DID
IN 2001.
AND WE HAVE TO MEET THE
CHALLENGES WE FACE TODAY.
WE RUN EFFECTIVE
COUNTERTERRORISM OPERATIONS
AROUND THE WORLD WHERE WE KNOW
TERRORISM IS MORE OF A THREAT
TODAY.
AND WE CAN AND WILL DO THE SAME
THING IN AFGHANISTAN WITH OUR
OVER THE HORIZON
COUNTERTERRORISM CAPABILITY.
COOPERATION WITH OUR CLOSEST
PARTNERS ON OUR ENDURING
COUNTERTERRORISM MISSION WILL
CONTINUE TO BE AN ESSENTIAL
PIECE OF OUR STRATEGY.
IN SHORT, WE ALL, ALL OF US
AGREE TODAY THAT WE'RE GOING TO
STAND SHOULDER TO SHOULDER WITH
OUR CLOSEST PARTNERS TO MEET THE
CURRENT CHALLENGES WE FACE IN
AFGHANISTAN, JUST AS WE HAVE FOR
THE PAST 20 YEARS.
WE'RE ACTING IN CONSULTATION AND
COOPERATION WITH OUR CLOSEST
FRIENDS AND FELLOW DEMOCRACIES.
AND I WANT TO, AGAIN, THANK ALL
OF OUR ALLIES AND PARTNERS
AROUND THE WORLD WHO HAVE
RALLIED IN SUPPORT OF OUR SHARED
MISSION.
WE ENDED THE CONVERSATION TODAY
BY A CLEAR STATEMENT OF ALL OF
OUR PARTS.
WE ARE GOING TO STAY UNITED
LOCKED AT THE HIP IN TERMS OF
WHAT WE HAVE TO DO.
WE'LL GET THAT DONE.
AND TOMORROW I'VE ASKED
SECRETARY BLINKEN TO GIVE YOU AN
UPDATE AND A DETAILED REPORT ON
EXACTLY HOW MANY AMERICANS ARE
STILL IN AFGHANISTAN, HOW MANY
WE GOT OUT AND WHAT OUR
PROJECTION IS.
SO THANK YOU AGAIN, AND GOD
BLESS